- Okay, let's get into our questions.
We have Anon from Zoom.
The question is, given
that the antibody titers
seem to reduce after 28 days,
do you know if the authors
tried to reinfect again
after a longer timeframe,
has there been any maybe
since this is a bioRxiv paper,
we often see some changes over some time.
Do you know if maybe they
started with a shorter timeframe
and then it increased it
and then added some
addition to it later on?
Is there any information around that?
- Yes so I mean, as gene is noted,
often these papers on bioRxiv are modified
or changed or attitude before
they get finally published.
I do know that this paper
was updated once already
and actually some more monkeys
were added to the study,
so I would expect that this
lab is probably ongoing,
and is doing these sorts
of experiments now.
But they haven't published that data yet.
So we don't know the answer
to those questions yet.
- Be really interesting
to see when they do.
Okay, well first of all,
that was a really lovely way
of explaining immune memory.
I really enjoyed that.
Thank you Joe.
And we have another question
from Zoom from Juan Wang
who wants to know if
there's any data showing
what the lungs looked like
right before the reinfection?
- That would be a good question.
And to be honest, if I was
reviewing this piece of work
as a peer reviewer,
it's probably something
I would ask the authors
if they had and if they could produce.
They did not produce it in
this particular experiment,
so we're not sure about that.
If I was speculating, I
would say that probably
the lungs had somewhat returned to normal,
inflammation like this can
take quite a while to go down.
So it wouldn't surprise me
if they didn't look perfectly normal,
but I would expect them
to suddenly have modified
from the extreme sort
of disease that they had
in the middle of an infection.
- Great, so I can also imagine that
this is a primate research project,
which is also a limiting factor.
So we have to take that very seriously.
Another question from Anissa on Zoom.
How are the viral loads
on the swabs measured?
Also the antibodies,
how are they measured?
So maybe we could talk a little
bit about maybe the RT-PCR
and the antibody testing mechanisms.
- Yeah, our colleague
Odaelys Walwyn-Pollard
has done a wonderful
D4P talk on antibodies
and antibody testing.
So if you're really interested in that,
I highly recommend you check it out,
she's a wonderful scientist.
How the virus is detected is we look
for it's genetic material,
and the genetic material that
you and I have is called DNA.
That's the form the
genetic material takes.
The virus produces genetic
material in a different form,
it's known as RNA.
And what we do is we
turn that RNA into DNA,
we use an enzyme, a
biological machine to do that.
And then we use that DNA
because the converted DNA
is easy for us to work with,
and we basically look
for the presence of that.
We amplify it, we duplicate it,
and then look to see if we can detect it.
So that's broadly speaking how we look for
the virus in those swaps.
It's actually an extremely
sensitive technique.
The way that these experiments are done
and it's the same kind of technology
that underlies detecting
DNA at a crime scene.
We're using this amplification process
to detect even really
small amounts of viral RNA
to enable us to get quite a good measure
of how much virus that was in the lungs.
- Great, okay, so we have
another question now from Kaitlin
who asks, if the length of
time that immunity lasts
for one strain of SARS-CoV-2 is different
from another strain.
Apparently Kaitlin has
read that some strains
could affect people as
severely than others.
What do you think about this?
- Well, so I wanna be careful
about using the word strain.
So, scientists mean
something quite precise
when they talk about different
strains of the virus.
So all the different copies of the virus,
much like all the different
people in the world
are slightly different probably, right?
Because, there were mistakes
made when duplicating
when copying the virus.
So, new strains of a virus
or actually what that really means is that
it has a different sort
of disease progress.
It's materially different in terms of
how the disease progresses,
the properties of the disease.
I'm not actually that aware of there being
definitively different
strains of COVID-19,
I'd be interested in what
you, Jeanie and Pedro
think about that.
So that's the first thing that I'd say.
- I think according to
a lot of the studies
there is definite a lot
of the viral researchers
studying this process right
now have demonstrated that
there is probably only one strain,
but obviously this is an RNA virus,
RNA and viruses don't have checkpoints
in their polymerases
though the Coronavirus
family has a rudimentary
proofreading capacity in their RNA base.
So that's one of the reasons
why the Coronavirus genome
is remarkably large
compared to other viruses.
But getting back to the
question of strains,
so I think the consensus
among researchers is that
there is a single strain
but mutations are occurring
because mutations are very natural
and they just occur.
And so you can trace the movement
of the virus geographically by
assessing the tiny mutations
that might exist within a specific strain.
So I don't think that
there's any data to suggest
that any of these mutations
are leading to a different enough virus
from the original virus that
started to infect humans.
And that's really relevant
because the affinity
for binding the ACE-2 receptor,
I believe has not yet
been shown to be different
among the particles that demonstrate
these tiny little mutations
that might be associated
with sort of the geographical locations.
I hope that was clear.
And I'm going to share an
article that was written
by a fantastic journalist, Ed Yong,
who describes this in more detail.
I highly recommend
that you follow Ed Yong's
coronavirus coverage.
It's really excellent.
- I completely agree.
I love Ed Yong,
but just also to the aspect of immunity,
even if there are some mutations
found in the coronavirus,
the immunity is generated
as Joe explained so well
on the stickiness of these
antibodies that are going to bind
the proteins on the
surface of the coronavirus.
And as far as I understand,
none of these mutations has
caused enough difference
in these proteins for them to
be recognized any differently.
- And I think so we do have a question
that is not related to the paper
but maybe related a little
bit to this process.
And so,
why is it so hard to develop
a vaccine for COVID-19?
And so there's currently no
vaccine for the 2003 SARS,
and I wonder if that's
because it was contained
and is now technically extinct.
- Yeah, I would actually
counter by saying,
I think relatively
speaking now we don't know,
we're still finding out
stuff about this virus,
but relatively speaking,
I would actually speculate
that this is a virus which
it probably will be possible,
probably will be possible to
generate a vaccine against.
And that's actually I'm
pretty sure that's the opinion
of Anthony Fauci who's the
top infectious disease expert
here in the United States.
There are other viruses
like HIV for example,
which scientists have been
trying for decades and decades
to generate viruses against,
and that's actually
proved really difficult.
So I think the answer
to this question really
is about people's expectations and timing.
There is a wonderful article
in the New York Times
which lays out the
timeline for how vaccines
are usually developed.
And it usually takes 20, 30, 40 years
to develop a vaccine against a virus.
And that's usually no small part
because of the different sort of testing
that we have to do on
the vaccine to make sure
that it's safe,
to make sure that it works.
And those tests take a long time.
And the basic research to find out
what is the best version of the virus
or fragment of the virus
to use in the vaccine
takes a long time.
So actually I think what we're gonna see
probably in this case is a vaccine
or multiple different
vaccine candidates developed
at breakneck speed,
relative to how long
vaccines usually take.
It's just that this
virus did really appear
and catch us flat-footed.
We hadn't done that much
research on this group of viruses
and we don't have
the progression of those
trials already happening.
We have to start from nowhere.
- I also want to clarify that
my colleagues have informed me
that there was indeed a
vaccine that was developed
for the original SARS in 2003,
and they stopped making it
because the virus--
- It kind of went away, yeah.
- Yeah, it went away.
- Okay, so next question from Danielle.
What is it about different viruses
that causes variable timeframes
of memory expiration?
That's a really good question.
So for examples, the example you gave
of measles against
influence or common colds.
- Yeah, this is a really good question.
And I think the answer,
we know some reasons
why this might happen,
but we probably don't
have the full picture yet
as scientists.
So if I think about some of the things
that we think about
and we think of as impacting how well
your immune system
works and but something,
usually people who have
more severe disease
and have maybe that
really debilitatingly ill
with the disease
will remember that disease
better than someone
who was only mildly sick.
So there seems to be some correlation
between how sick you get
and how well your immune
system is gonna remember it.
Also may depend on the amount of virus
that your pathogen you're
exposed to at the beginning
and there are lots of other things
that probably we don't know.
Some viruses, so flu is a
really interesting virus.
There's actually multiple
different types of flu
and multiple different strains of flu.
And so we think of flu
as being a capsule term,
but really when you get flu the next year,
it's not actually the same virus
that's infecting you for a second time.
It's probably a different
strain of the virus.
So flu is very difficult to contain
and remember for your immune system
because it's basically like
someone that keeps changing
their clothes, right?
Your immune system has
to recognize this person
and it thought, "Oh, okay,
I remember this person.
They were wearing red
pants and a blue shirt."
And then sort of comes in the next time
and it's wearing a yellow
shirt and green pants.
And your system has to recognize it again.
And basically has to
relearn everything again.
So that's why flu particularly
is not very well remembered.
- Yeah, I think that that also answers one
of the questions we
had from Octavia around
what makes a virus more memorable.
It's really tricky,
and I think our colleague at Rockefeller,
John Laurent Casanova,
talks about host factors.
So the factors that we contain,
genetic differences in
our bodies that could also
dictate our immune memory
or our immune responses in general.
And so all of this is
really just an amazing,
I think it's still kind of like a mystery
for many scientists out there.
It's the million dollar question.
And I think the COVID-19 situation
that we're currently in right now
is definitely driving the research
on a lot of these questions in ways
that we've never seen before.
So I think a lot of this
might come out in the future.
I mean, at least I feel positive
that we are gonna make a lot
of progress in these areas
given the amount of attention
it's being provided.
So, we have another question from Wan
about the livelihood of the monkeys.
Did monkeys one and two pass away
or were they just used as a control?
Why weren't they not reinfected?
- So the second part of your question
whether used as a control
that's really important.
So scientists definitely need that.
So if you're gonna make a comment
about how the monkey
responded to reinfection,
you need to be able to
compare it to a monkey
that was not reinfected.
And the reason for that is,
let's say you reinfected
the monkey 28 days
after the first infection,
it's possible that there
was just a delayed response
which took 28 days
and it's only gonna
appear after you've done
the second infection.
And you might then wrongly
attribute that response
to the re-infection when actually
it was just a delayed response
from the first infection.
So it's very important to
have controls and certainly,
that's true of the monkeys that
were already infected once.
In answer to the overall like
livelihood at the monkeys,
there were definitely
unfortunately monkeys
which died in the course
of this experiment.
I kind try to give an outline
of the sorts of
considerations that are given
to an experiment like this
even being allowed to happen
in the first place,
and there will have been a good number.
I can't speak to the process
at the particular institution
where this paper was done.
I know it's an accredited institution,
but at Rockefeller, there's a panel
which consists of the generians
and it has outside people
who are not affiliated
with the university on it.
You have to approve every
animal experiment that's done
and sign off on it and
say this is acceptable.
And we use those As,
the three As to guide us
in our use of animals.
And we only choose to use
an animal like a monkey
when it really is necessary
for advancing the science.
I don't know if Pedro or
Jeanie have anything else
to say about that?
- I think that's pretty much covers
a lot of my expertise around this.
I have not ever worked
in a primate lab myself,
but I do know people
think extremely seriously.
These are very carefully planned
and scientists go to extreme
measures to make sure
they're using the fewest
amount of animals possible
to get the results that are rigorous
and applicable to whatever
disease it is that they need to,
for example, the COVID-19
in this case, right?
And so these are hard questions
and I think that I appreciate that people
are exploring this year,
because we are in a situation
where we can't take humans
and re-infect them to see what happens.
Well, there are people who
are signing up for this
kind of stuff,
so it's a difficult decision
that we have to make.
- Yeah, then you study
the disease as it goes
in hospitals and with the
patients you have access to.
But obviously that's not the same thing
as having everything controlled
in a time controlled manner
in a laboratory setting,
which you do with monkeys,
which you obviously have to reduce
to the minimum possible amount.
But that actually leads us very nicely
into our next question from Luke,
who wants to know whether the
lung biopsies that you showed
were biopsies or were post-mortem slides,
and also what your view is
on the monkey immune response
as compared to the human immune response
to different strains of COVID-19.
- Yeah, so that second
part is of consideration
that every single biologist
is worrying at night about,
about whether that particular animal
is the same as a human, for example.
But lemme address the first one first.
So those were post-mortem slides done
after an autopsy on the monkey.
But the second part
with respect to how similar
is a monkey's immune system
to a human,
I mean, the reason this
experiment was done on monkeys is
because monkeys have the
most similar immune system
to humans.
And so in a situation like this
where we have an extremely
important time sensitive question
about a pandemic that's killed hundreds
of thousands of people,
we want to get an answer
which is translatable
to humans as quickly as possible,
with as high degree of
certainty as possible.
And so that's why we would use
a monkey in this situation.
They do have the most similar
immune system to humans
as other animals that we could use.
So I would say
we know that they are extremely similar,
there will be some modest differences.
And we do our best to work those out
and apply what's learned
in monkeys to humans
with enough modesty that
we don't think we know all
the answers and we acknowledge
that it is possible
but it would behave slightly
differently in a human.
- So we have a very smart
question from Aaron,
around immunological memory.
So going back to that aspect,
and Joe, or if anybody else
on the panel of scientists
are here and maybe you would chime in
if Joe, this might be outside
of your area of expertise.
So in terms of the immune system's memory,
is this related to how
path pathogens mutate?
For example, is the reason our
immune systems don't remember
the common cold infections,
but do remember measles infections
because the cold virus
mutates a lot more quickly,
but the measles virus does not.
And how quickly is the novel
Coronavirus mutating relative
to other viruses and our immune system?
- Okay, so the answer
to the first part about
whether memory is related to mutation,
it definitely is related to mutation,
but that's also not the full story.
So for example,
HIV is a virus
which is extremely promiscuous
in how it replicates itself,
and as a result it makes lots of mistakes
and you take a huge amount
and that's why it's very
difficult for your immune system
to respond to it.
And I was just talking about flu
and I use the analogy of the flu
sort of changing clothes every year
and making it difficult
for your immune system
to recognize it.
So that definitely has a role in shaping
how well a particular
pathogen is remembered.
But I do also want to say that
it doesn't explain it all.
There are definitely pathogens
which for whatever reason seem
to elicit extremely
strong immune responses
in certain people and be
remembered extremely well,
and other pathogens which may
be a less easy to remember.
And that might also be to
do with how sort of sticky
the pathogens are.
So if you have a pathogen
which is extremely sticky
and it's very easy to make antibodies,
which will stick extremely well to it,
maybe it will be remembered very well.
But if you have a pathogen
which is a bit slippery
and it's quite hard to stick to,
that one might be remembered less well.
I don't know if other people,
and they're definitely
people on this panel
who know more about this than me.
Oh, sorry, in response to the second bit,
I think Jeanie already mentioned this.
The Coronavirus actually
relative to other viruses,
which are RNA viruses,
it mutates quite slowly.
And that's because it
has this ability to check
whether it's doing a
good job in replicating.
Check the fidelity of it's copying
of its genetic information.
So when it's duplicating
its genetic information,
if it makes a mistake,
there is a piece of
machinery which can say,
"no, you've made a mistake.
Chop that bit out and redo it."
And other RNA viruses don't have that.
So they make spelling mistakes
when they're replicating
the genom more often.
So relatively to those viruses,
it mutates less quickly.
- Well, thank you.
We do have another question
from an anonymous attendee,
which speaks a little bit to
what we were discussing earlier
about experiments with monkey packs
and the differences from humans.
And they ask if you
know whether the monkeys
were all hanging out together
for this experiments?
Meaning, where the monkeys separated?
And would this have an effect
on how sick the monkeys got
or how effectively they became immune?
- I mean, I think this
is a fantastic question
because one of the other
things that gets out is,
one of the problems with this disease
is you can't treat all
people as individuals,
people associate in groups,
for example, in a family unit.
So, it's quite likely that
if one of those people
in those family unit gets infected,
it's gonna spread around to other people.
So there are definitely
dynamics that come into play
when you start thinking
about how organisms
or humans or monkeys grouped together.
I can tell you in this experiment,
the monkeys would not have been allowed
to be in a group together
because if one of the monkeys gets better,
we don't want it to
confound the experiment
by being reinfected by
one of the other ones
which is still sick.
And so they will be housed separately,
and in monkey kind of housing,
they usually have toys, they have mirrors,
they have things like that,
which it's called enrichment.
Basically to make the monkey
happy and give it stuff to do.
And so that's the sort
of conditions under which
they're usually housed.
But again, I don't even work
with any animals in the lab.
I only work with cells in Petri dishes,
I'm certainly not a primate researcher.
- Thanks Joe.
Okay, so we're gonna
take one final question
because we are at one hour and 15 minutes
but the conversations
have been so wonderful
that we were reluctant to
close it down after an hour,
and we are gonna end with
a question from Adidi.
Adidi you have asked a
question at every single D4P.
So thank you very much,
I hope you're well.
It's so nice to see you on here.
So Adidi was one of our SSRP students,
so that's exciting that
you're joining us here.
Okay, this is a fantastic question
around male, female differences
and potential role of hormones.
And so as the research indicated
the female immune system
is better than fighting the
outbreak due to differences
in hormone levels.
I'm not sure if the
research has indicated,
I know that females tend to get COVID-19
at a lower frequency than males,
but it's not clear that's due to hormones.
So I just wanna throw that out there,
but I love the way that
you're thinking here.
Do you know if hormones play
any role in immune memory?
- So this is totally
over my head, I do not,
but let me make one comment.
Which is that, in relation
to this hormone question,
it's very difficult to tease
out the different parts
of what's having an impact in science,
particularly in human experiments.
Because we know for example,
that men smoke more often than women.
And smoking is obviously gonna
be pretty bad for your lungs.
And it's a risk factor for
having a worst prognosis
if you get a respiratory disease.
So seeing that man are
getting a particular disease,
worse and have worse
outcomes as a result of it,
might be to do with biological variation
caused by hormones
or it could be to do with other things
which also are to do with being male.
So if men smoke at a high rate,
then really what's happening is it's not
that being male is causing
you to develop COVID worse,
it's that smoking is causing
you to develop COVID worse
and smoking as a factor correlates
with sex somehow.
So we have to be very careful
when thinking about those things.
I personally do not know
anything about hormones
and their impacts on the immune system,
but I don't know if one
of the other panelists
can shed some light on that.
- Immunology is definitely over my head.
I'm just a plain old geneticist so
(laughing)
I think Joe what you've
raised here is sort of like
the problems that we face in the lab
or in clinical studies, in the field
it's really hard to boil
something down to a single reason.
- Exactly.
- [Jeanie] Yeah, and
so it's multifactorial
and I think there's gonna many years
of research being done
to really fully give us
any kind of a picture moving forward.
And it's Dr. Pollard who is
on here is just texting us
to tell us it's really
hard to tease out hormones
and their impact on the immune system.
And yeah,
it's a hard question
but I appreciate that people
are thinking in that direction
because I think we have to keep thinking.
And so good job on that.